[Music]
nothing is one of Enys biggest csgo
players but what does it mean to be the
best in na to be perennial e at the top
of a region that can't compete with the
scenes top international talent what
becomes of your legacy when winning is
almost always just out of reach until
then well go through to the
quarterfinals once again in a major
cloud nine will be going home what
becomes of your legacy when the team you
hoped build finally
across a decade of plain cs
professionally nothing saw it all the
highs the lows and every crushing loss
in between and yet his legacy has
remained untarnished this is his story
[Applause]
geordan nothing Gilbert was born on
October 25th 1990 in San Diego
California and was the youngest of three
brothers like many of today's eSports
pros nothing got his start in his game
of choice by watching his brother Jared
play counter-strike
but even before that nothing always had
a flair for competition and wasn't going
to let other kids walk all over him we
joined this little roller hockey league
kids were kind of picking on him a
little bit so I went over to kind of
protect him and he pushed me back and he
goes I got this but at home nothing was
obsessed with video games specifically
counter-strike 1.6 I homeschool Jordan
for the 12 years he was in school on his
off time he wanted to play video games
how could I say no when he was doing all
his work and when I saw how effortlessly
he was improving and growing so fast I
just decided that I was gonna go as far
as well to go with it
she was playing 10 to 12 hours of CS a
day non-stop and then going out to small
land tournaments and rolling people the
only problem was that nothing was much
younger than his adult opponents a lot
of the older kids that were playing did
not like the fact that they were getting
waxed 9 of ten-year-old players so
there's an older brother stood by to
make sure that things didn't get out of
hand which they did a few times
nothing knew that the only way to make
it big was to play as much as possible
in front of as many people as possible
so he leaned on his mother who drove him
to land after land all on Nothings quest
to become the best so one of the biggest
things for me succeeding the local scene
and probably getting the opportunities I
did was getting notoriety from competing
in tournaments in LA and Las Vegas and
I'm
was the key factor in getting me there
and it all paid off a few years later
when nothing signed with evil geniuses
at just 18 years old so at that point
amazing gaming we won a code five
qualifier and got picked up by evil
geniuses and that was like my first pro
contract that actually had like a salary
and then every year for the next four
years
eg were the best North American 1.16
they won the ESEA season 3 finals the
IEM for American finals the ESEA Season
5 finals ESEA season 6 finals and the
beat it 2010 finals but when it came to
international competition eg always
fought he's gonna get the Frog and
that's gonna be another round 2 SK as we
approach these last round they said oh
you've got way that's it 1 to 8
all the while nothing was developing a
reputation he had an aggressive high
octane style that made him thrilling to
watch and his young age made his
wunderkind status all the more
impressive I'm gonna be showing you guys
today a bit about m4 gun control and
just showing you the different aspects
of it and basically all the different
battling techniques you'll need for the
different distances and situations
you'll encounter but after so many years
of top na eg finally crumbled in 2011
the team fell to 9th 10th at IEM
Hannover then failed to make it out of
groups at IEM six global challenge New
York and capped off the year by placing
3rd at the WCG pan-american tournament
during that same time nothing was pretty
uncertain about his life
eg was paying him a salary but it wasn't
enough to live off so we started going
to college and even got a marketing
internship at Gunnar but the internship
just made him jealous it was kind of a
weird blow to my ego because I was like
dealing with a gaming industry but in
like this behind-the-scenes way and I
was like helping other pro gamers from
like League and Starcraft do cool stuff
and I remember being jealous like man I
wish my game had more traction Evil
Geniuses left counter-strike in January
2012 disbanding their team after months
of rumors and speculation that left
nothing in the lurch one-point-six was
on the way out and csgo
the game sequel was quickly becoming a
game of choice but go wasn't perfect and
when it came out
nothing wasn't even sure if he liked it
I hate how him PS go they made it more
about strategy and less about [ __ ]
just easy like and 1.63 cool is
obviously easier to control but the
strategy was much more prevalent because
you could actually hold angles and you
can't reach [ __ ] around up like an idiot
by yourself and this game [ __ ] pure
idiot everywhere but what nothing didn't
realize at that time was that csgo was
perfect for him now very early on there
was a clip of him like actually kind of
criticizing a certain aspect of the game
and while he's talking and having a
conversation he's just casually getting
four kills and around just just running
forward and you know it just seems so
effortless Dillman and so we all thought
that Jordan would just be incredible at
this game because it just seemed to fit
his style so much
nothing bounced around several rosters
as csgo started to gain traction playing
with some of any's best rising talent
his last team team dynamic was quickly
noticed and signed by long-running
eSports org complexity gaming the team
played in the first two csgo majors
brand-new tournaments with massive prize
pools funded by valve making it into the
top eight both times and nothing after
just a few months of playing go that
plek city roster changed hands again
this time they were acquired by
up-and-coming eSports org cloud9
the team that nothing would spend the
rest of his professional career way csgo
was growing in ways that 1.6 could never
match esports was growing at a rapid
pace thanks to growing prize pools more
interest from sponsors and increased
viewership on Twitch that meant there
was a legion of brand new CS fans kids
who never played CS 1.6 and were looking
for a team to love and cloud 9 gave any
fans bad team Oh
ashes to pre this position right here
he's about to get flashed right through
nothing cloud 9 hey couldn't have gone
better
the team was among the best in na in
those early days of csgo
but perhaps more importantly nothing was
providing fans with a look behind the
curtain what do you guys say right now
the camera how long's what do you think
were gonna win by Robin are you playing
are you playing our game
nothing would constantly vlog and take
behind-the-scenes videos early on in
csgo
endearing himself to fans and bringing
them closer to the team and his goofy
personality going to Stockholm
get in she reads made by Shelly
Taranto's unfortunately that was a lot
of what there was to like about c9 there
were one of Enys best but just like eg
they crumbled in the face of
international competition the time is
ticking
he's got 17 help he has to push out
Dupree will line the shot and tears and
will go through to the quarterfinals
once again in a major cloud nine will be
going home
cloud nine placed 9th 12th at Dreamhack
winter and ESL one Katowice a 2015 and
until the spring they continued to be
stymied by European teams at every
tournament they attended in April c9
made a switch bringing on skadoodle and
freakazoid to replace Shazam and SEM
ffice then after a few weeks of feeling
out the roster they were suddenly on the
upswing couple a cheese Anneliese gonna
go in now with a trance they both get
limited straightaway and congratulations
we have a winner cloud line will
actually win 2-0 over Team Liquid and
they will be crowned the champions of
the htc reborn Invitational so and they
were just the best team in na we were
finally hanging with the European teams
what a long map has been for them but
overpasses up next route he's got the
double he's gonna get the triple there
it is
I look at freakazoid absolutely fired up
unfortunately they work winning and now
it's hold on Shroud he is 17 seconds and
he goes for the fighting goes down and
now we are gonna win it 1614 and you can
tell the impact of foul line there oh
wow
cloud9 were the undisputed best team in
na and while they could compete
internationally they weren't ever able
to push themselves the rest of the way
past the finish line it's something
grateful fantastic they've done it time
and again
two major championships and here it is
they are war Victor's hit at ESL esea
pro league season 1 that summer they
were perennial e second-place finishers
behind the european teams that beat them
time and time again the summer of c9
came to an end at the two majors of that
fall a c9 placed 9th 12th back-to-back
at both ESL one cologne 2015 skadoodle
has been to many of major and he has
never made it out and with cloud 9 I
think this is honestly the best shot
that he had and still denied incredible
and Dreamhack cluj-napoca 2015 they're
not gonna hear him coming there's too
distracted they're too preoccupied
trying to get towards the site and it's
watch so that they run into again it's
all said and done - straight maps for
that
cloud9 unfortunately North America
they're bowing out here yet again
shortly thereafter team captain sean
gares left the team and was replaced for
the 2016 season and at least for the
first few months the roster move didn't
go according to plan
it's all on shroud 1 vs 4 and G 2
they'll do one better than Envy no less
but it's cloud 9 once more that
completely dismantled in a major at MLG
Columbus cloud 9 washed as Team Liquid
rose up and placed third fourth the
highest finish and na team had ever
attained at a major meanwhile cloud 9
were out in dead last c9 s place as
anaise best team was officially taken
over and the team went into a roster
freefall
they lost freakazoid added a dren than
Slammy then automatic all while getting
rid of their manager and coach the cloud
9 that ruled na was well and truly done
in its place there was a new cloud one
that for a while looked pretty solid in
the flash works but nothing's not fully
blinded he's good in the flash betting
dances he gets the head shot back
against a fax in automatics not sure to
rotate because they are still trying to
play nothing he's turned back he's
figured it out of that shot as well as I
said shot on happy they were a team that
could once again compete with the top
international teams and he's got a smoke
out and they'd throw him but he's gonna
try and bait out this palm plant bake it
watch window there's a chance that goes
through nothing spray
secure their place in the grand final
but they couldn't win on top of the
balcony position they're gonna try and
bait it automatic Tonio's got the first
shot automatic still in behind the hunt
he's still not beat on this he's gonna
try and cut them out for the broken wall
he does get one but now it's just him
remaining and he's on to 16
[Applause]
Dreamhack Open champions in a very very
convincing tournament these guys cease
to stop an easy against americanas once
more they dominate USA at least not
until the ESL pro league season four
finals last time it was nothing but
schedule eights another shot Chris goes
down Stewie's pulled it back now it's
just two remaining and it's low HP on
the two mousesports players but sweetie
gets me Stewie doubts skadoodle
countered off in the gun jumping across
he's on 13 28 kills first canoodle in
the game and cloud 9 is going to a final
cloud 9 went on a tear at the EPL season
for finals and in a complete upset
brought down hometown favorites SK
gaming in front of a crowd of cheering
Brazilian fans
it's called tear a bomb down automatic
in a 1vs1 he's got no idea where
automatic is he's rotated all the way
too long and cold might get caught he's
looking down toward the dories in the
to give globulin season for and that duo
of Stewie brothers Stewie and automatic
together on cloud nine is what brought
them back to form and they show it in
the last round to clutch it back I'm
trying not to cry yeah I've played this
game for a long time to beat these guys
here it means a lot to me and you know
that my team played amazing today so I
could say all the cliche things right
now I'm just really [ __ ] excited
things were looking up for cloud 9 they
made it into the Atlanta major close
qualifier and we're back to playing well
in na
despite their continued failures
internationally but nothing helped c9
crawl their way back up the ladder
they beat SK again at the Subaru
Invitational qualified for the major
with a first place finish at the minor
and third fifth at the close qualifier
and even took a shocking second-place
finish at ESL one cologne 2017
[Music]
but once again it all came crashing down
at the major it's nothing between virtus
Pro and playoffs can he do it though all
the experience as much experience as the
veterans of BP but no it's gonna be
purchased Pro the home team in front of
the home crowd live on Friday at the
torn arena here at the PGA major clown 9
left the krakow major in 9th 11th place
not dead last this time but not good
enough to guarantee a spot in the next
major they needed a change and all eyes
were on its oldest members on August 15
2017 just a month after their
catastrophic major exit cloud9 dropped
shroud and nothing
the last remaining founding member of c9
s csgo team and so it was either we're
gonna make a change with someone else
and we made units so you said it I was
like alright maybe that's all I need to
know I almost was a relief because we
were in this like limbo for a while as a
team that we needed something to change
shroud for his part had been talking
about retirement for over a year and was
ready to live the streaming lifestyle my
eyes I actually upset for like 2018
are you serious
no I'm serious like I met I've told
pretty much everyone this like oh one
more one more solid year but nothing
approached things differently
he had been playing CS professionally
for over a decade when he got benched
for perhaps the first time in his entire
life he had gone from a wunderkind
superstar to early csgo adopter to
beloved personality and then all of a
sudden people thought he was washed up
kind of sad to see nothing go out but I
guess like even if you're a critic of
turrican tarik for nothing still
obviously feels like an upgrade for me
and rush I think he's [ __ ] mental I
think he's insanely good meanwhile his
contract with cloud 9 meant that he
wasn't able to play for another team
until May 2018 nearly a year away so we
decided to double down on bringing his
personality to the fans that's fine
actually
she's pretty scary I've done it before
down in Blair Heights well it's gonna be
fun so hopefully we get some good shots
on the helmet if not gonna be really sad
maybe I'll sneak to go put my pocket if
I can't fit it on the mouth and then
just rub it on recording that meant more
streaming oh my goodness
and even getting in front of the camera
as an analyst dude if he's always had
quite a wild playboy pudding there in
their private it was pretty wild to play
them on maps like Kabul cuz they almost
had a different playbook betting on who
they played but while he was redefining
his identity in the CS scene cloud 9 was
redefining their own identity in CS
I don't expect us to win every
tournament I don't expect us to do
making our groups every time I do expect
us to compete at a really high level
though making it hard for the teams to
beat us making us unpredictable even
grabbing a few ones here and there and
to me after falling apart in cracow the
new roster was sharp and went on a tear
3rd 4th and ESL one New York eleague
we've seen an incredible performance mr.
doodle so far this tournament been a
long time since I think we've seen him
at this level where he's just hitting
shots he's clutching for his team he's
making the difference and IEM Oakland
all right that a semi finals about to
happen let's just hear it from you who's
winning this is it phase
so busy cloud9 in semi-final tie
cloud9 was looking like the best in na
again and while they weren't winning
every significant tournament they were
placing well and truly competing with
international rosters and then at the
Boston major cloud9 shocked the world by
bringing down faze clan 2-1 in the grand
finals becoming the first ever na major
champions Guardian waits patiently as
crowd biceps to push up
[Applause]
major champions
[Applause]
but they did it without nothing nothing
isn't necessarily upset that his team
won the major without him in fact in a
certain light it's not really his team
anyways it's not the team he built but
the org he stopped with not being there
for the win hurt sure but the way the
team fell apart afterwards proved to him
that maybe stepping back from the team
was the right call and even thinking
about obviously just like wish I would
have made really like every player
wishes they won a major but not like
I'll funk these guys like I think it was
actually best that the team made those
decisions to part ways i pressure left
the team earlier or change something on
the team earlier when i had a little bit
more of say in what would happen nothing
has gone back to play just a little most
notably he stood in for mousesports at
ESL 1 Belo Horizonte and helped the team
to a second-place finish in Brazil yes
definitely not replacing Oscar that
guy's a god offer he's got a special
role in this team I'm just happy to be
here and not cause them any problems be
able to stay with the pace they want to
play I'm proud to say that you know
without a lot of practice I'm still able
to show up and do what's necessary to
beat top teams in the world and I'm just
really happy to play in front of this
great crowd while playing for mouths
nothing got a chance to play with Rob's
the team's rising young star who sights
nothing has an influence for why he got
into CS in the first place I mean I
started playing 1.6 when I was around 7
and like that was a long time and
nothing was like the same age as me and
he had like a lot of these good matches
and frag movies which I really still
look at nowadays and he's probably the
person I look up to and ask for what
comes next
nothing says that's still up in the air
I've been create a kind of little
ecosystem and that's kinda what I'm
doing I'm not opposed to like playing
again but the problem is is a lot of
teams want a certain level of commitment
so all these things are happening and
then I'm it like I'm advising a couple
companies passively
you know you know this I put out this on
my stream a couple times I thought it'd
be awesome if I weren't playing and to
create an org but you know you know
building an org is not like hey you
wanna make it which in itself is a sign
of what nothing has become to CS trans
it's been a long time since nothing was
the young hotshot savant he was known
for being in 1.6 it's been a long time
since he was one of the best players in
na it's been a long time since he's even
been on a successful roster but there is
something about nothing that is always
true
nothing will always be a crowd favorite
his legacy is one of excellence but
perhaps more importantly of a player who
wasn't afraid to pull down the curtain a
little be honest with his fans and teach
people about the game so what's cool for
me as a shrimp right now is to keep
educating and keep pushing kids to get
better because really what keeps
two-seam thriving is all the the big the
largest group of players they're like
not super competitive guys having fun
playing it because they are trying to
get better or whatever reason implants
our friends and sense of community so
nothing's legacy in csgo will likely
remain forever but the work he does now
in that liminal state between player and
retired personality is sealing him in as
one of na s most important CS
personalities the educating he does the
fans he keeps interested in the game and
the ability he has to inspire young
players will only become more important
to the
as it matures thanks for watching if you
want more great content just like this
be sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]